the year is 2022 and here you are still
immune to the charms of from software
you've resisted popular opinion and
decided that dark souls a series so
highly regarded so wildly influential
that it and its associated games have
spawned the sub-genre affectionately
known as soulsborne is quote not for me
look we get it they're hard there's no
getting away from that i mean the
special release of dark souls was called
the prepare to die edition which is
certainly going to ring alarm bells for
anyone hoping to dance through while
enjoying the story
don't worry we're not judging and we're
certainly not here to tell you to get
good
that's for the commenters to do
what we are here to do is give you seven
excellent reasons to break the habit of
a lifetime and make elden ring the new
dark fantasy action rpg from bandai
namco games your formal introduction to
the twisted world of front
we know that there are going to be some
devoted soulsborne fans checking into
this video to make sure we're not
leading would converts astray so we'll
also cover why elden rings many changes
are good news for the faithful too
because we're kind like that
fromm dabbled with non-linear
adventuring in its 1994 debut king's
field and has continued to explore the
limits of player directed progression
ever since
demon souls hub allowed you to choose
the order in which you tackled its
discrete worlds
dark souls offered multiple routes and
skippable bosses through its largely
seamless land of lordran and sekiro
introduced fluid vertical navigation for
greater moment-to-moment freedom of
choice
as fromm's first truly open field game
elden ring is the largest expansion on
this concept we've seen yet
while you can't see absolutely
everything the lands between offers from
the get-go the opening area of limgrave
provides a vast open space that you can
explore freely for you beginners that
means you won't be funneled into
challenging dungeons and punishing boss
encounters and can choose to enjoy the
sense of discovery leveling up gaining
valuable items and generally growing
more confident in your abilities
conversely that means the opposite is
also true for the experts if you want to
take a wretch the weakest starting class
straight to difficult areas intended for
higher level play that's entirely up to
you you madman
from emphasizes that eldon ring is
firmly grounded in elements that from
has always prioritized and the aptly
named legacy dungeons and the promise of
new game plus will make you feel right
at
home seoul's mastermind hiretaka
miyazaki says that he believes more
players will finish elden ring than any
of his other games and the game's
producer yasuhiro kitau claims that it's
a perfect title for those who have been
put off by concerns about the games
being too difficult
in fact from promises that they have
made a major effort to reduce player
stress
solsborne games like the similarly
portman toad metroidvanias present
increasingly naughty labyrinthine
worlds
unlike the latter however souls borns
traditionally provide no map forcing you
to rely on your memory of its
distinctive spaces to get around
eldon ring is much kinder in that regard
with from taking some of the stress out
of navigating its largest world yet by
adding a beautifully illustrated map
complete with checkpoints that let you
fast travel to previously discovered
locations we can see how this might not
be too revelatory to first-time players
but trust us it's a big concession to
accessibility around these parts
additionally there are stakes of marika
curated respawn areas typically placed
close to areas that the creators expect
you to have trouble with
this can prove useful for recovering
dropped runes elden rings currency and
generally take the stress out of
repeatedly revisiting challenging
encounters emphasis on repeatedly
regular players needn't be too concerned
though the arrival of a map doesn't mean
you'll be tracking objective markers and
waypoints so dark souls organic sense of
discovery remains additionally the map
is of the overworld only so any dungeon
or legacy dungeon you happen across will
still be an uncharted labyrinth that
you'll need to memorize on your own
traversing the expanse that is the lands
between entirely on foot would be a new
level of sadism even for from so they've
introduced a spectral steed
traveling on horseback is entirely new
to the soulsborne dynamic providing an
expanded suite of exploration and combat
opportunities
this otherworldly horse is instantly
summonable which makes a lot more sense
than your average instantly summonable
horse and it lets you gallop through the
world at greater speed
don't worry about the more vertiginous
aspects of the landscape either wind
currents called spirit springs will
propel you both skyward so you can keep
riding around elevated areas the landing
would probably break the legs of a
normal horse so strike another win for
supernatural stallions
riding horseback brings a new dimension
to combat 2 letting you attack enemies
from your elevated position not to
mention make a quick getaway if things
get too rough just be aware that some
enemies also have mounts so horse on
horse violence is inevitable spectral
steeds certainly aren't some kind of
stealthy easy mode though fighting on
horseback is more an alternative combat
option that's better suited to some
situations than others and dungeons have
a strict no horse policy
the magnificent world of eldon ring is
the product of a unique and unexpected
collaboration between two brilliant
creative minds
from enlisted the help of a song of fire
and ice author george r r martin to
create the mythology of the world
providing a detailed multi-layered
backstory of grand heroic demigods
corrupted by the power of shards of the
shattered elden ring
that fantastical history provided the
foundations on which hidetaka miyazaki
the game's director and writer could
then build on in ways that even martin
himself might not have predicted players
will be introduced to the lands between
in the aftermath of a cataclysmic event
known as the shattering
contrary to the stories told in the
souls games fromm wanted to tell a more
accessible tale where the protagonist
isn't forced into conflict but is in
control of their own story your
motivation is straightforward enough you
are one of the tarnished who lives
outside the lands between until a vision
claims that you must defeat the
corrupted demigods to reunite the pieces
of the elden ring and become the elden
lord
soulsborne games always have a memorable
cast of npcs who can be reliably
depended upon to deliver cryptic
exposition usually accompanied by tragic
backstories
elden rings huge open field also means
more npcs who will help to reveal more
about the events transpiring in the
lands between and likely trigger
additional quests you won't be quite as
dependent on the narrative jigsaw puzzle
that is piecing together the flavour
text from collected items but fans will
be relieved to hear that they still play
a major part in relaying lore
from other masters of fragmented
storytelling giving you just enough to
create a picture of the world's history
while leaving plenty to the imagination
the wealth of items in elder ring
promised that george r.r martin's world
building stories will be told
after dialing way back on character
customization in sekiro from has turned
the dial all the other way for elden
ring this is their most detailed most
flexible creation system yet
if you're anything like us it could be
hours before you even set foot in the
lands between and that's just the
aesthetics before you hone your look you
must first decide on a starting class
however as has always been the case with
the souls games and in a refreshing
departure from many rpgs you are not
locked into your initial choice while
you'll certainly have an early advantage
in specific talents if you feel that
you'd like to switch it up from say a
heavy melee user to a sorcery wielding
mage you can simply re-weight your stats
as you level up and with a wealth of
close combat arranged weapons sorceries
and incantations to discover it really
pays to keep mixing things up as to how
this flexibility translates out on the
field the open environments present a
different challenge to the souls games
there the claustrophobic environments
and deliberately limiting pathways meant
that it was simpler for from to
choreograph ambushes leading to
extremely cautious and heavily reactive
play here the greater visibility
provides more opportunity to anticipate
encounters and approach them in a way
that suits your build strengths or if
you prefer run in the opposite direction
and find a long way around for rpg fans
who are a little wary of the
action-centric nature of soulsborne
titles there's other avenues to explore
stealth is a completely legitimate
option throughout the game and with the
new day night cycle and weather elements
you can use cover of darkness or the
visibility reducing effects of heavy
rain to bolster your sneakiness but
let's be clear with from promising a
high battle encounter rate on the field
souls inspired legacy dungeons and yes
those trademark boss encounters combat
proficiency is still a major focus
if all this talk of battling counter
rates and boss battles has you worrying
don't
in addition to stealth
spirits are a brand new element for
those who need a helping hand throughout
the game you'll discover these friendly
phantom creatures who can then be
summoned into battle this is especially
useful for multi-opponent combat as
they'll interrupt incoming attacks and
give you more time to concentrate on
taking down individual enemies likewise
with bosses where they'll provide a
useful distraction so you're less likely
to be destroyed and given more of a
chance to observe attack patterns as
with the other stress reducing features
spirits have been thoughtfully
implemented and even though they can be
individually strengthened they've been
kept relatively weak overall they're
also entirely optional so if you have
concerns about their effect on the
game's difficulty you can decide to
forgo the assistance
[Music]
co-op has always been an acceptable way
to even the odds in souls games even for
players who might have just been a bit
sniffy about those spirits we just
mentioned
of course fromm didn't want to make it
too easy to pair it with other players
so the actual act of summoning help was
made deliberately arcane compared to
other online experiences while alden
ring hasn't exactly introduced lobbies
and instant matchmaking it has in the
words of miyazaki reduced the number of
hoops you have to jump through there's a
variety of in-game items designed to let
you tailor the multiplayer experience
and in true souls born fashion most of
them are gross with a particular
emphasis on severed fingers
you can also add password protection
when requesting assistance if you only
want to play with friends but as souls
fans well know teaming up with
experienced strangers can be just as
enjoyable just be aware that anyone who
joins you is subject to a variety of
limitations they are very much guests in
your world so they can't activate
checkpoints and if they die they're
immediately expelled and must be
re-summoned the asynchronous elements
first introduced in demon souls make a
return so expect to see plenty of
messages from other players to make you
feel a little less alone in this
intimidating world
expect to find hints words of
encouragement and the occasional piece
of mischievous misdirection hint if a
message tells you to jump off a cliff
the only reward you're likely to get is
a you dyed screen for those more
well-versed in from's complex approach
to multiplayer pvp also makes a welcome
return just as there are severed fingers
to invite support there are other
varieties that allow you to welcome
invaders or attempt an invasion yourself
just be gentle with the new kids yeah
the elden ring
[Music]
for all of us
you